Judge Andrew Napolitano of Fox News has
long argued a hardcore libertarian
position on the nation's largest cable
news network
consistently holding George W Bush
Barack Obama and now his friend Donald
Trump accountable for alleged abuses of
power in the judges analysis the Muller
report on Russian interference in the
2016 election lays out multiple
instances in which President Trump
attempted to interfere with the
investigation thus making him guilty
under federal laws governing the
obstruction of justice if he had ordered
his aides to violate federal law to save
a human life or to preserve human
freedom he would at least have a moral
defense to his behavior but ordering
them to break federal law to save him
from the consequences of his own
behavior that is immoral that is
criminal that is defenseless and that is
condemnable the president responded with
a series of hostile tweets claiming that
among other things the Politan Oh had
asked to be named to the Supreme Court
and had requested a pardon for a mutual
friend
Napolitano sat down with reason to
defend his name lay out his case against
the president and put Donald Trump's
presidency in a historical and
constitutional context
judge welcome thank you the thing that
got this started was your reaction to
the Muller report you've said that the
president the president claimed that the
report completely exonerated him and its
campaign showing no collusion and no
obstruction of justice you disagree
where is the president wrong first I
reject the word collusion that word was
insinuated into our vocabulary very
shrewdly I might say by Rudy Giuliani so
that he could say the president's not
guilty of collusion and by the way
occlusion is not a crime well that's a
circular argument the crime is
conspiracy an agreement to accept
something of value from a foreign
national which is unlawful in a
federally monitored campaign I I didn't
see the underlying evidence but a
hundred and twenty seven communications
between the Trump campaign or the Trump
Organization and Russian intelligence in
a 16-month era would be enough to prick
my curiosity and want to look a little
deeper but that's not what I'm
challenging him on I'm challenging him
on whether or not there was enough basis
to prosecute him for obstruction of
justice and there clearly was the reason
in my view Bob Muller did not ask for
permission to seek an indictment and
under the bill Barr managerial ship of
the DOJ you had to ask the Attorney
General for permission to seek the
indictment as Barr has this bizarre
narrow view of the obstruction statutes
which would have caused Barr to say no
I'm not gonna let you go to a grand jury
with this in attorney general bars of
you it is impossible to commit
obstruction unless you actually
committed the crime being violated and
you're trying to obstruct efforts to
investigate the crime that you've said
Barr is saying because there was no
conspiracy there there couldn't be any
obstruction trying to make sure that if
this were so then Richard Nixon couldn't
be charged with obstruction of justice
unless he was actually one of the
Watergate burglars underbars theory
that's how absurd it is we also know
that it's been rejected uniformly
Mayor Kwame Kilpatrick of Detroit was
convicted of obstruction of justice for
interfering with an investigation into
his extramarital affair not a crime
Martha Stewart was convicted of famously
of obstruction of justice for
interfering with a prosecution of her
for insider trading even though the
insider trading charges against her had
been dismissed and very tellingly
at the very moment that bill Barr was
making his you must be guilty of the
insider crime nonsensical Jesuitical
sophistry arguments his own Department
of Justice was announcing an indictment
of a Massachusetts Superior Court judge
for obstruction of justice her crime she
has before her an illegal immigrant was
there on a disorderly persons charge he
was drunk and disorderly was a nonsense
charge the back of the courtroom are ice
officers this is the government's
version not hers she says to the ice
officers we're gonna release him into
the lobby of the courtroom courthouse
her sheriff's officers released him to
the parking lot and he escaped she was
indicted for obstruction of justice
the underlying crime re-entry into the
United States after deportation what she
couldn't possibly have committed so by
bar accepting this narrow view and I
only know two people that hold this view
the Attorney General and former Harvard
Law Professor Alan Dershowitz Bob Muller
knew that that didn't even pay to
recommend pursuing him pursuing the
president obstruction says what's an
example of him actually trying to
obstruct me oh they're that like many of
his minion cases they'll do his bidding
greater obstruction is defined as
impeding or attempting to impede for a
corrupt purpose with an investigation or
a judicial proceeding a corrupt purpose
is defined as one that benefits the
obstruct er so if for example he said to
katie mcfarland my former Fox News
colleague oh there's this problem with
the ambassador in Flint you know just
put a letter in the file and claim that
this is what they what the conversation
was about knowing the father was about
to be
that's an effort to impede he says to
Don begin you said what to the FBI
go back and tell them you were wrong you
want me to like uh packets on your room
that's an effort to impede so there are
numerous examples depending on how you
read them there's either 10 or 12 of
those examples in the Muller report this
one that's a little interesting there
such as something about the president's
character we now know why he was so
determined for general Flynn not to be
prosecuted in general Flynn was lying at
prosecutor for lying to the FBI about a
conversation that may have been lawful
or may not have been lawful conversation
with the Russian ambassador Kissel yak
about sanctions why do you have that
conversation general Flynn and his plea
negotiations told Muller the president
told him I have a conversation if the
president I'd revealed that I don't
think that Mike Flynn would have been
prosecuted but that revelation never
came what the president wanted to hide
is that he is the originator of the
conversation why does he fear it because
it happened before he was president and
so if the incoming but not yet their
administration says to Russia don't
worry about sanctions we're gonna take
care of you once we're in office that
violates a federal statute which
prohibits interfering with the country's
foreign policy as a matter of law is it
settled whether or not a sitting
president can be indicted on criminal
charge that is a very good question the
Justice Department you probably don't
know this because it's never been
explained properly on in the media has
three opinions one says no the other
says no the third says yes but they all
say if the statute of limitations is
about to run the president can be
indicted the indictment can be sealed
and he won't be prosecuted until he's
out of office all three of them agree on
that so do you think that's likely to
happen no but it should have it won't
happen while bill bars the Attorney
General because of this view that he has
the supposedly academic view but there's
no support for it of you must be guilty
of the underlying is bar a particularly
bad Attorney General Oh Nick
I mean the built bar that I know when he
was the head of the Office of Legal
Counsel in the early years of the George
HW Bush administration so that's the
think tank within the DOJ that tells the
rest of the DOJ what the law means and
from there he became the Attorney
General wrote the original memo to the
president about the constitutionality
and virtues of mass warrantless
surveillance so right there it's very
difficult for me to find good about him
it would be an unbelievable good would
be angels coming down from heaven type
good to outweigh an evil that pernicious
and pervasive because from that single
memo developed the 60,000 domestic spies
we have now that work for the NSA so
let's talk about Donald Trump in the
context not not about his personality
per se but as a president he's coming on
the heels of George W Bush Barack Obama
to president Julaine basted for massive
kind of violations of constitutional
strictures on power when you think about
Trump from a constitutional point of
view or from executive power is he the
same as these guys is he worse or is he
better
we certainly not better he's either the
same or worse me broughal you tell me
which is bad which is worse Barack Obama
using drones to kill people no due
process and no declaration of war but
reporting the killings Donald Trump
using drones to kill people and not
reporting the killings and well not
which is Burnett various points he's
like we got to get out of stupid Wars it
doesn't get us out yeah yeah I mean do
you think that what's happening in
Caracas is happening without the CIA's
involvement I mean if they topple Maduro
who's gonna pay for assuring up their
economy right like your
great-grandchildren mr. government
doesn't have the money they have to
borrow it so what do you see in the
Democratic nomination the people running
for the Democratic presidential
nomination is there anybody there who is
good from a kind of presidential power
constitutional perspective where is this
is it just you know darkness all the way
down I think it's darkness all the way
down again it depends on what you mean
that's good when I talk to Democrats on
eronel
and I say what is the overriding issue
they all say one thing it's not Medicare
for all it's not redistribution of
wealth it's not warren piece it's not
marijuana it's not civil liberties it's
defeating Donald Trump they wouldn't
care who defeats Donald Trump or what
the person's ideology is as long as it's
anybody but Trump that's their attitude
there's there's not a libertarian drop
of blood not one drop in all their
bosses will have what are we doing to
take that back yo Bernie Sanders has
some libertarian inclinations when it
comes to spying and civil liberties what
about Joe Biden who's currently you know
riding not only is he you know writing
the top of the pulse among Democrats but
you know he's he would if the election
was held tomorrow he would beat Donald
Trump yeah how bad is he in terms of
kind of civil liberties and
constitutional limits on power
well Barack Obama ran as a civil
libertarian which as you know this is
very divisive amongst our friends
enticed some people to vote for him and
his record as a United States Senator
from Illinois was fairly commendable
when I came to civil liberties he became
the president and he did a 180 degree
flip I don't know where Biden would be
on these things I think the government
would be a lot more bipartisan and civil
if he were president but in terms of
civil liberties I don't think it'd be
any better than the president under whom
he served there must be some horrific
temptation once you're inside 1600
Pennsylvania Avenue
I think Grover Cleveland was the last
president who ever vetoed legislation
because it was unconstitutional did you
ask to be nominated to the Supreme Court
I did not but I was asked by him to
discuss the court for about three hours
in to 90-minute conversations both alone
and with others and you said you gave a
spiel what is what's the elevator pitch
of like not that you want to be on the
Supreme Court but what would you bring
to the Supreme Court well I I described
to him I was describing Neil Gorsuch and
him thought I was describing myself you
know I described a courageous
libertarian revolutionary who would
undermine the administrative state or at
least seek to do so the only one of nine
votes who would you know undermine and I
ticked off a couple of particular
Supreme Court opinions that vastly
expanded federal power and he found
those arguments appealing do you feel
the court is moving in the right
direction in terms of you know kind of
what Steve banning called deconstructing
the administrative stage well on
deconstruct in the administrative state
yes on the primacy of the individual
over the state absolutely not what do
what do you mean by that what well the
the conservative wing of the Supreme
Court is is not into individual or civil
liberties the Fourth Amendment is going
to be shoved in a drawer and a couple of
years what we have politicians who don't
care about individual rights right
we have justices who don't care about
individual rights right where does where
does change come from in this scenario
well we have a president that doesn't
care for individual rights but we
haven't had a president who cares about
individual rights in our lifetime I
don't know where where the impetus will
come from even the so-called
libertarians in the Senate you know
Herriman take out my iPhone so what's in
here personal professional medical
financial
intimate if Brett Kavanaugh is world the
government does not need a search
warrant to get in here they get us get
in here electronically did you hear that
discussed at his confirmation hearings
absolutely not did anybody bring that up
Liberal Democrat or conservative or
libertarian Republicans no there were
more interested in how many ice cubes he
spat out at some woman at Yale 30 years
ago because both parties are in favor of
big government and the and the
surveillance state I don't know that's
going to be cracked short of a bloodless
revolution where does that revolution is
it is it in our hearts this is I start
in the heart Sam Adams
Tom Jefferson I don't know if you know
parts of the country will start to
ignore Washington Washington will be so
bankrupt it can't pay its bills
no one will lend it money I mean Trump's
borrowing a trillion dollars a year and
even the Republicans and the senator
probably gotta let him borrow another
trillion he had some agreement just the
other day with mrs. Pelosi and Senator
Schumer two trillion dollars we're gonna
repay route 84 the George Washington
Bridge to the Oakland Bay Bridge where's
the two trillion going to come from
you already borrowing a trillion a year
they don't care about the potentially
catastrophic consequences of debt which
will be ignoring the government so it
might work out they bite okay what we're
gonna leave it there thank you so much
for coming ending on a happy Judge
Napolitano yeah finally
final lap back so much pleasure
[Music]